sie hatte ihren sohn auf einem
hubschrauberflug der luftwaffe richtung
süd in den osterurlaub mitgenommen die
bilder von diesem flug landeten im netz
und nun haid lamprecht den politischen
schaden obwohl das ganze wohl rechtens
ist die ministerin scheinbar die
regularien eingehalten hat kann es
durchaus folgen haben denn die union
wirft ihr maximale ungeschicklichkeit
vor und die fdp fordert lamprechts
rücktritt erhard scherfer ist für uns in
berlin beobachtet in dieser woche das
sitzungs geschehen des bundestages er
hat wie unangenehm kann diese geschichte
für frau lamprecht 'noch werden zumal
sie ja bisher nicht wirklich als große
stütze dieses kabinetts in erscheinung
getreten ist
ja ich glaube unangenehm ist das
richtige adjektiv bei der ganzen
geschichte ich glaube nicht dass das
größere und schwerwiegende konsequenzen
haben wird denn es gibt derzeit
tatsächlich aktuell erheblich größere
probleme in der welt und auch in der
republik als diesen hubschrauberflug der
ja zunächst ein dienstlicher war und der
wie sie richtig sagen auch entsprechend
angemeldet wurde was die mitreise des
sohnes angeht das ganze wird kostenmäßig
erstattet werden durch die
bundesverteidigungsministerium also es
gibt ja auch eigens regularien dafür ist
es also gar nicht unüblich dass
angehörige an solchen reisen teilnehmen
wenn das ganze ordentlich abgewickelt
wird spricht eigentlich im grunde nichts
dagegen das einzige was man anmerken
kann ist ob es nicht vielleicht ein
bisschen cleverer gewesen wäre in einer
solchen situation auf solche
angriffsmöglichkeiten zu verzichten oder
sie im vorfeld verhindern denn jetzt
kommt tatsächlich wieder neuerliches
viel kritik zum tragen und die wäre
sicherlich nicht zwingend nötig gewesen
wir sind bei den stellungnahmen der
fraktionsvorsitzenden und wir gehen live
zu spd zu rolf mützenich
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
ich darf sie begrüßen zum statement mit
rolf mützenich vor unserer
fraktionssitzung die wir erstmals in
dieser legislaturperiode im
fraktionssaal abhalten können
deswegen sind nachher auch auftakt bilde
erlaubt allerdings bitte sehr geordnet
und nur mit maske reingehen
hoffe es nicht beginnt und dann kommen
wir zu ihren fragen wir haben meine
damen und herren herzlich willkommen
hier auf der fraktionsebene und wir
robben und sozusagen immer wieder zu der
normalität voran und in der tat wir
freuen uns wenn sie gleich vor beginn
unserer fraktionssitzung auch wieder in
unseren räumen begrüßen dürfen und seien
sie da nicht böse wenn ich werden wir
die debatte beginnen dann bitte das sind
ein hochschüler den fraktionen sei
verlassen mussten weil wir doch durchaus
das eine oder andere politisch werden
besprechen wollen insbesondere vor einer
sitzungswoche die in der tat einen
großen noch mal anlauf nimmt im hinblick
auf die entlastungs pakete wir werden
zweite und dritte lesung im deutschen
bundestag haben um die bundesbürgerinnen
und bundesbürger die unter eben
steigenden energiepreisen aber auch
nahrungsmittelpreisen leiden eine
perspektive zu geben wir haben
gleichzeitig aber auch die
rentenanpassung debatte in erster lesung
wo ich auch sage vor dem hintergrund der
entlastungspaket wollen wir jetzt die
wirkung uns natürlich genau auch noch
mal vor augen führen ausrechnen lassen
und dass wir dann möglicherweise eben
auch wenn zusätzliche entlastung
notwendig sind und darauf deuten auch
neueste zahlen hin wir natürlich
insbesondere auch die gruppen noch mal
in den fokus nehmen die nicht sozusagen
konzentriert von den jetzigen
entlastungs paketen profitieren das
betrifft rentnerinnen und rentnern aber
auf der anderen seite in der tat eine
starke rentenanpassung die wir auch dann
in erster lesung jetzt hier im deutschen
bundestag beginnen werden wir
diskutieren aber auch über die
abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a und
viele andere aspekte noch die uns
wichtig sind und die glaube ich auch aus
der situation heraus dass der
koalitionsvertrag hier versprechen
gemacht hat jetzt auch eingelöst werden
das ist wichtig das betrifft auch die
oster pakete die erneuerbaren energien
so dass das also eine volle
sitzungswoche ist und auf der anderen
seite würde ich wenn sie erlauben gern
die bemerkung im hinblick machen dass
ich froh darüber bin dass die ansprache
die fernsehansprache des bundeskanzlers
am sonntag am vergangenen sonntag nicht
nur nochmals zusätzlich neben anderen
erläuterungen klar gemacht hat was der
gemeinsamen kurs in der bundesregierung
ist und dass er auch von vielen
offensichtlich nicht nur gesehen sondern
auch unterstützt worden ist auf der
anderen seite die besucher der
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas und
eben auch jetzt heute aktuell der
außenministerin zeigt dass gerade auch
die solidarität gegenüber der ukraine im
hinblick auf den überfall der russischen
streitkräfte auf befehl von präsident
putin im augenmerk der politik der
bundesregierung aber auch dieses
parlaments ist und wir werden hier einen
dieser woche auch erneut besuch vom
ukrainischen außenminister haben zum
schluss würde ich dann gerne auch noch
einmal darauf hinweisen dass wir in
dieser woche weiterhin gespräche über
die frage der verankerung des
sondervermögens im grundgesetz führen
und wir da vielleicht dann auch in der
nächsten woche abschließend zu beraten
werden vielen dank kommt mit ihren
fragen frau kohler zwar die gäste
ja er wird ziemlich wie beurteilen sie
denn die erziehung von
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht dass
sie ihren sohn mit in regierungsämter
mitgenommen hat sie alles richtig
gemacht oder wie die opposition
kritisiert war das nicht richtig dass
man sich jetzt gelesen und gehört haben
scheint mir doch alles richtig gemacht
worden zu sein vor dem hintergrund der
richtlinien und das eintreten eines
privaten urlaubs wird ja mit sicherheit
auch so gut vorbereitet dass man daran
nichts kritikwürdiges finden wird
im anschluss an die frage das ist
anschluss an die frage der kollegin das
ist zwar kein skandal aber häufen sich
die eventuell bei der minister und
ministerinnen die die fettnäpfchen wie
schätzen sie das ein nun ich glaube es
geht überhaupt nicht um fettnäpfchen
sondern die verteidigungsministerin ist
in einer ganz besonderen herausforderung
auf der einen seite die
hinterlassenschaften von vorgänger und
vorgängerinnen im amt und auf der
anderen seite natürlich auch die
situation des krieges in der ukraine wo
ja eben auch versucht worden ist in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten auch
militärische ausrüstung von seiten der
bundesregierung der ukraine vor dem
hintergrund des selbstverteidigungsrecht
es zu überantworten und von da ist es
eine große herausforderung die aber
dennoch natürlich insbesondere wenn es
um die gestaltung von privaten
aktivitäten gilt die auch gut
vorbereitet wissen aber christine
lambrecht ist er mit sicherheit erfahren
genug dass sie hier alles dafür getan
hat für die transparenz und auch für die
rechtmäßigkeit der steuer
was zu den verhandlungsprozess
sondervermögen sagen die union sagt man
braucht unbedingt diese woche eine
einigung muss bei dieser einigung dann
konkret schon einen wirtschaftsplan mit
projekten vereinbart seien ja oder nein
und es ist hilfreich wenn die union sagt
die zwei prozent müssen nicht unbedingt
ins grundgesetz die können auch einfach
so ins gesetz geschrieben werden das
wäre die erste frage und die zweite
frage wäre wenn sie erlauben zum thema
hartz 4 und sanktionen gibt es da eine
gemeinsame linie inzwischen in der
koalition was das thema moratorium
angeht ja wenn ich das vorweg nehmen
dafür haben uns geeinigt beim
sanktionsmoratorium
sozusagen für die jetzige für die
jetzigen fragen aber auch das was in
zukunft für das bürgergeld entwickelt
wird in welchem sanktions haben wir uns
auch bewegen wollen dass die union
natürlich intensiv mit uns zurzeit
verhandelt insbesondere mit der
bundesregierung der finanzminister
lindner ist beauftragt wurden über das
sondervermögen mit der opposition eben
auch zu sprechen das finde ich sehr gut
ich habe überhaupt gar keine
schwierigkeiten damit wenn wir in dieser
woche zu einem abschluss kommen würden
auf der anderen seite liegen aber auch
noch ein paar fragen auf dem tisch um so
wichtiger ist dass die union sich auch
bewegt von fundamental forderungen
abstand nimmt und das zeigt ja auch die
einigung die wir in der letzten
sitzungswoche doch so geschafft haben
über einen gemeinsamen antrag der
fälschlicherweise als waffenlieferung
antrag beschrieben worden ist er aber
die gesamte palette der politik
gegenüber der ukraine diplomatie
humanitäre hilfe wirtschaftlichen
wiederaufbau finanzielle unterstützung
umfasst hat und die union hatte ja
damals nur fünf worte verändert so dass
sich auch der hoffnung bin dass sie
daraus vielleicht die eine oder andere
lehre auch im hinblick auf das
sondervermögen ziehen könnte
endlich können sie vielleicht nur noch
einmal zum sondervermögen sagen was aus
ihrer sicht die knackpunkte sind und wo
man vielleicht noch etwas weiter
auseinander liegt nun ich glaube
knackpunkte sind gar nicht sozusagen der
punkt wo wir nicht so einer einigung
kommen sondern das was die union uns auf
den weg mitgegeben hat herr merz hat ja
erklärt dass die zweidrittelmehrheit nur
insofern gesichert wird er sehr eine
zahl von abgeordneten zur verfügung
stellt ich finde das einen sehr
interessanten umgang mit der freiheit
des mandats wir dies auch gegenüber
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen
vielleicht verantworten will ich hätte
ihnen wenn er mich gefragt hätte dazu
nicht geraten wir gehen davon aus dass
die gesamte unionsfraktion dieser
staatspolitischen verantwortung vor dem
hintergrund einer beachtlichen summe der
ausstattung mit militärischem gerät aber
auf der anderen seite auch ausstattung
für die soldatinnen und soldaten uns
dabei unterstützen wird der krieg in der
ukraine ist ohnehin für das land selbst
aber natürlich auch für europa eine
große belastung und wenn ich mich noch
an die regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers erinnere mit welchem
enthusiasmus sie auch in der
unionsfraktion insgesamt aufgenommen
worden ist kann ich nur hoffen dass die
union uns dabei auch in der nächsten
woche unterstützen wird wird uns
der optimismus in allen ehren was ist
der plan b
über plan b
wertig
vielleicht kennen sie mich jetzt ein
bisschen
in dem sinne schon gar nicht in der
öffentlichkeit etwas ausbreiten und ich
würde auch gar nicht mit herrn merz über
plan b reden wollen
jetzt kommt uns
rolf mützenich der vorsitzender der spd
fraktion jetzt haben wir eine kleine
irritation hier aber wir haben sie schon
überwunden hat einen kleinen überblick
geben über das parlament geschehen in
dieser woche hier im deutschen bundestag
auch angesprochen einige aktuelle themen
die uns gleich in den nächsten minuten
auch noch mal wieder begegnen werden
aber hat auch angesprochen das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr diese
100 milliarden die angekündigt worden
sind vom bundeskanzler mitte februar und
dann gibt es im moment wasser auf die
mühlen der kritiker denn am montag hat
einen ausschuss eine an eine anhörung
stattgefunden des
haushaltsausschusses unter haben
ökonomen und finanzrechtler heftig klage
erhoben gegen das vorhaben dieses
sondervermögen zu haben gesagt das
widerspreche haushalts grundsätzen es
gebe kein sei ein gravierender
systembruch und es gebe vor allem eine
mangelnde verzahnung zwischen dem
regulären verteidigungshaushalt also da
scheint es noch einiges an kritik zu
geben auch in der spd und bei den grünen
in deren fraktion ist ja dieses
gesamtpaket nicht ganz unumstritten
insbesondere in welche richtung all
dieses viele geld dann unterm strich
gehen soll aber wir sind in einer
sitzungswoche und das heißt wir schauen
weiter auf aktuelle themen und auf die
wie im bundestag verhandelt werden und
hören uns an die stellungnahme in dieser
zu dieser sitzungswoche des vorsitzenden
der fdp-fraktion und das ist christian
dürr und er hat bezug genommen auf das
geschehen rund um den krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine
die armee von wladimir putin wütet
mittlerweile seit mehr als zehn wochen
in der ukraine
und dass die außenministerin
deutschlands und unsere
parlamentspräsidentin in die ukraine
reisen ist ein ganz starkes zeichen der
verbundenheit und der deutschen
solidarität aber die furchtbaren
nachrichten aus der ukraine brechen
leider nicht ab während wir hier den 8
als tag der befreiung begangen haben
zeigt es dass wir fundamentale werte des
friedens in unserer mit unmittelbarer
nähe immer wieder bedroht sehen und auf
das schlimmste missachtet werden das
muss ein ende finden und deswegen ist es
vollkommen richtig dass wir in der
vergangenen sitzungswoche des deutschen
bundestages hierzu sehr klare position
nicht nur gefunden haben sondern mit
breiter mehrheit beschlossen haben sie
wissen ja dass die ampel fraktionen hier
einen antrag eingebracht haben in den
deutschen bundestag wir haben uns
gefreut dass die union diesem antrag
beigetreten ist der insbesondere sich
auch mit der lieferung schwerer waffen
beschäftigt hat das tut die
bundesregierung das ist gut so und
dieses breite signal aus der
demokratischen mitte des hauses war ein
ganz wichtiges signal denn ist bleibt
richtig nur so kann sich die ukraine
auch verteidigen und wie furchtbar
dieser russische angriffskrieg ist zeigt
ja auch die bombardierung der schule im
gebiet von lohans das sind furchtbare
bilder die uns von dort dann erneut
erreicht haben und ich betone das was
ich letztes mal bereits gesagt habe an
diese bilder dürfen wir uns nicht
gewöhnen ich will gleichzeitig einordnen
das aus meiner sicht die gestrige rede
von präsident putin anders alles andere
war als eine verbale abrüstung obwohl
die russische armee hohe verluste zu
verzeichnen hat und unsere bisherigen
insbesondere wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
zu immensen wirtschaftlichen schäden in
russland geführt haben geht es nach wie
vor entschlossen für die ukraine diesen
krieg fortzuführen und entsprechend
unterstützen wir die ukraine genau dabei
also wir müssen diesen druck auch von
deutscher seite aufrecht erhalten und es
war daher eine richtige entscheidung des
bundeskanzlers alle maßnahmen so zu
wählen dass wir genau das auch über
längere zeit durchhalten können ich
komme zu einem zweiten punkt in dieser
sitzungswoche und dass das thema
entlastung ein besonderes anliegen
natürlich der freien demokraten in der
letzten sitzungswoche haben wäre bereits
beschlossen dass die eeg-umlage für alle
unternehmen in deutschland für alle
privaten haushalte
vollständig abgeschafft wird das ist
angesichts der gestiegenen strompreise
notwendig gewesen und sie wissen dass
wir damit ja den koalitionsvertrag sogar
über erfüllen das war geplant die eeg
umlage zum ersten januar kommenden
jahres abzuschaffen das ganze ziehen wir
ein halbes jahr vor und in dieser
sitzungswoche wird es um weitere
entlastungen gehen wir werden das
steuerentlastungsgesetz im deutschen
bundestag beschließen mit einer anhebung
des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrages des
grundfreibetrages der pendlerpauschale
und all das rückwirkend zum ersten
januar 2022
dazu kommt dann noch die energie
pauschale für erwerbstätige und der
bonus beim kindergeld wir haben hier in
kürzester zeit entlastung in höhe von
bislang 37 milliarden euro auf den weg
gebracht und damit als ampelkoalition
mehr spürbare entlastung geschaffen als
der bundestag in acht jahren
unionsgeführte bundesregierung
der dritte bereich sind die aktuellen
weiteren gesetzesvorhaben die wir in
dieser woche im deutschen bundestag
haben da wäre zuerst zu nennen der
schnelle ausbau von lng terminals das
sichert insbesondere unsere weitere
energieunabhängigkeit auch im hinblick
auf den konflikt in der ukraine und im
konflikt des westens mit russland und
sichert unsere energieversorgung
nachhaltig wir sind uns in diesem
zusammenhang einig dass wir die
genehmigungsverfahren ja drastisch
verkürzen wollen und ich sage das ist
eine blaupause geradezu für künftige
veränderungen der beschleunigung gerade
bei großprojekten das sollten wir weiter
beobachten und entsprechend übernehmen
denn das wird dazu führen dass wir
insgesamt unsere wirtschaftliche stärke
die jetzt besonders wichtig ist weiter
voranbringen der dritte punkt an
gesetzesvorhaben die ich ansprechen
möchte ist die abschaffung des
paragraphen 219 atem strafgesetzbuch der
ebenfalls in die erste lesung in dieser
sitzungswoche geht damit legalisieren
wir endlich die ärztliche aufklärung
über schwangerschafts abbrüche ist es ja
absurd geradezu gewesen in der
vergangenheit dass das verboten war also
dass diejenigen die sich sehr gut
auskennen und die am besten substanziell
frauen informieren können dass es ihnen
verboten war das ist aus meiner sicht
insbesondere angesichts der die
abtreibungsdebatte in den vereinigten
staaten auch ein wichtiges zeichen
hier gilt mein herzlicher dank unserem
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann
ebenfalls für die schnelle vorlage und
ich glaube diese beispiele die
entlastung die drei innovationsvorhaben
die wir hier einbringen das zeigt dass
die ampel progressiv vorangeht als es
viel progressiver als es die
unionsgeführten bundesregierung in der
vergangenheit getan haben das betrifft
insbesondere die wirtschafts- und
energiepolitik genauso wie die bildungs-
und gesellschaftspolitik
christian dior der vorsitzende der
fdp-fraktion mit seinen einlassungen zur
aktuellen lage und zu dieser
sitzungswoche und wir können direkt
weiter machen mit der unionsfraktion
denn auf dem weg zum mikrofon sind schon
der vorsitzende der cdu/csu-fraktion
friedrich merz und der erste
stellvertretende vorsitzende dieser
fraktion alexander dobrindt und ich geb
direkt rüber steht natürlich ganz im
zeichen der so überragend gut gewonnenen
landtagswahl in schleswig holstein
wir werden noch einmal kurz diese wahl
analysieren auch über die landtagswahlen
am nächsten sonntag in nordrhein
westfalen sprechen die stimmung in der
union in der partei wie auch in der
bundestagsfraktion ist ausgesprochen gut
wir gehen sehr zuversichtlich jetzt auch
in dieser woche und auch in die
landtagswahl am nächsten sonntag aber
natürlich steht alles was wir hier
besprechen diskutieren unverändert unter
dem zeichen dieses andauernden krieges
in der ukraine es gibt im augenblick
keinen aktuellen entscheidungsbedarf zu
den verschiedenen themen die damit in
verbindung stehen das einzige was wir
sozusagen mittelbar besprechen werden
ist die steigende inflationsrate in
deutschland die ja auch etwas mit diesem
krieg zu tun hat nicht nur aber auch
etwas mit dem krieg zu tun hat wir
werden hier insbesondere einen antrag
besprechen zum thema inflationsrate
bekämpfen und preisstabilität
gewährleisten wir haben der koalition
einige vorschläge zu unterbreiten unter
anderem zur beseitigung der sogenannten
kalten progression die wir gerade jetzt
im zeichen der preisentwicklung für
dringend geboten halten wir werden auch
den vorschlag noch einmal erneuern dass
die koalition diese 300 euro energie
geld die sie jetzt für
versicherungspflichtige beschäftigte
steuerpflichtige beschäftigte erfunden
hat wenn man so etwas schon macht dann
bitte auch für rentner und studenten und
nicht nur für diejenigen die
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
sind aus unserer sicht ist das völlig
inakzeptabel dass rentner und studenten
die nun von der preisentwicklung und
auch der energiepreisentwicklung genauso
betroffen sind wie alle anderen
haushalte von dieser regelung
ausgenommen werden wir wollen noch
einmal die koalition bitten endlich das
handelsabkommen mit kanada in kraft zu
setzen das könnte einen beitrag auch zur
angebotsseitige entlastung der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher in
deutschland sein wir werden noch einmal
zum thema machen die flächenstilllegung
deutschland ist das einzige land in der
europäischen union das von der
ausnahmeregelung die die eu kommission
gewährt nämlich flächenstilllegungen
jetzt auszusetzen um die
lebensmittelproduktion zu erhöhen keinen
gebrauch macht wir sprechen hier über
etwa 50.000 hektar fläche die zur
verfügung stehen könnten wenn die
bundesregierung denn diese ausnahme in
anspruch nehmen würde die die eu
kommission gewährt und das letzte ist
wir bitten die bundesregierung fordern
die bundesregierung auf sich in der
europäischen union für ein belastungs
moratorium einzusetzen
es wäre angesichts des preisauftrieb ist
richtig und notwendig jetzt auf alle
maßnahmen auch auf der europäischen
ebene zu verzichten die zu weiteren
belastungen der unternehmen und der
privaten haushalte führen insbesondere
was die preisseite betrifft das ist
unser kernthema für diese woche wir
müssen etwas gegen die hohe inflation
tun wir wissen dass die europäische
zentralbank überwiegend für die
preisstabilität verantwortlich ist aber
die bundesregierung sollte es auch
unterlassen ihrerseits preistreibende
entscheidungen zu treffen die die
privaten haushalte in deutschland
insbesondere die niedrig den
niedriglohnsektor weiter belasten ich
zitiere in diesem zusammenhang immer
gerne ein altes wort von norbert blüm
inflation ist der taschendieb des
kleinen mannes und die koalition sollte
sich insbesondere jetzt um diese
einkommensgruppen kümmern die von der
inflation und den preisauftrieb am
meisten offen sind wir werden darüber in
der fraktion beraten und einen
entsprechenden antrag in dieser woche in
den deutschen bundestag einbringen
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren zuerst
auch wir gratulieren daniel günther zu
diesen großen
wahlerfolg und wünschen jetzt gute
entscheidungen für eine zukünftige
regierungsbildung wir haben in dieser
woche weiter verhandlungen mit der ampel
regierung über das ermöglichen der 100
milliarden
sondervermögen sprich sondern schulden
für die bundeswehr die verhandlungen
haben am montag begonnen werden im laufe
dieser woche auch weiter anhalten ich
bin noch mal sehr deutlich daran
erinnern dass die rede zur zeitenwende
des bundeskanzlers olaf scholz ein
doppel versprechen beinhaltet nämlich
100 milliarden für die streitkräfte und
zwei prozent dauerhaft bei den
verteidigungsausgaben
dieses doppel versprechen des
bundeskanzlers ist für uns der maßstab
wir fordern dass ein die verhandlungen
die wir führen die gespräche laufen in
einem guten einvernehmen ab aber sie
haben bisher kein ergebnis und es ist
nach wie vor offen ob dieses ergebnis
erreicht werden kann wir bestehen darauf
dass die doppel versprechen des
bundeskanzlers eingehalten werden dass
es unser auftrag um am schluss einer
grundgesetzänderung zustimmen zu können
wenn es dafür keine bereitschaft gäbe
dann wäre dieses vorhaben gefährdet aber
dafür gibt es zurzeit verhandlungen aber
noch kein ergebnis aber diese
verhandlungen werden im laufe der woche
weitergeführt und habe kurz zeit für
fragen frau schweiz auf eine ard zuerst
eben gesagt man sei bereit durchaus auch
diese woche sich zu verständigen einem
sondervermögen aber die union müsste
jetzt mal auch von ihren
maximalforderungen
abstand nehmen sind sie dazu bereit und
zweite frage beurteilen sie denn die
private dienstreise der
verteidigungsministerium wir warten seit
zehn wochen
auf das gespräch das erstmalig gestern
abend stattgefunden hat wenn die
koalition einen solchen zeitdruck
gesehen hätte hätten wir zweieinhalb
monate zeit gehabt die gespräche zu
führen ist gibt seit gestern abend das
erste mal bereitschaft der koalition uns
wenigstens hier in teilen
entgegenzukommen ich habe das gerade
noch mal im fraktionsvorstand
festgehalten wir lassen uns nicht unter
zeitdruck setzen hier geht sorgfalt vor
geschwindigkeit es gibt große probleme
im zusammenhang mit der
verfassungsänderung die vorgeschlagen
wird die sachverständigenanhörung
gestern hat hier sehr klar und deutlich
auch hinweise gegeben wo die probleme
liegen wir wollen das ergebnis wir legen
hier keine künstlichen steine in den weg
wir wollen die bundeswehr wirklich
besser aus und aufrüsten aber wir sehen
überhaupt keinen grund das jetzt in
dieser kürze der zeit eventuell sogar
bis nächste woche zu entscheiden wir
sprechen hier über eine wirklich
grundlegende änderung der regeln unseres
grundgesetzes im hinblick auf die
neuverschuldung und die
gesamtverschuldung und deswegen gibt es
hier ja wir wollen das zügig machen aber
wir lassen uns nicht unter zeitdruck
setzen
wir haben keine maximalforderungen
sondern wir stehen an der seite des
bundeskanzlers und seinen doppel
versprechen über die zeitenwende und
wenn die spd fraktion jetzt davon
spricht dass wir von unseren forderungen
ab gehen sollen dann fordert sie dass
der bundeskanzler olaf scholz seine
zusagen und versprechen aus seiner rede
zurück nimmt dafür haben wir kein
verständnis sondern wir erwarten dass
die spd-fraktion sich an das hält was
der bundeskanzler auch versprochen hat
wir zumindest stehen zu diesen zusagen
wollen sie erfüllt sehen und das in
einem ordentlichen verfahren dazu gibt
es diese woche die gelegenheit aber kein
grund von dem was der bundeskanzler
hut ab zu reichen
die kolleginnen und kollegen sind dabei
auch die entsprechenden nachfragen zu
stellen ob da alles auch den richtlinien
entsprechend durchgeführt worden ist die
mitnahme von familienangehörigen ist
grundsätzlich nicht verboten aber sie
hat nach bestimmten regeln zu erfolgen
und ob diese regeln eingehalten worden
sind das überprüfen werden denn noch
eine letzte frage von dem herren daneben
konkret danach gefragt ich meine das ist
jetzt ganz kann dahl aber insgesamt
reihen sich da nicht die fettnäpfchen
bei dieser verteidigungsministerium ja
also ich sag mal so wenn sie bei allem
so eifrig in ihren dienst geschäften
wäre wie bei der mitnahme ihres sohnes
dann stünde es um die verteidigung und
um die bundeswehr besser in diesem land
also ist es dringend geboten dass hier
transparenz hergestellt wird und kann
der verteidigungsministerin nur raten
dass sie in dieser woche das parlament
informiert über die umstände und die
inhalte dieser reise dann kann man eine
bewertung entsprechend vornehmen das
schlechteste was wir zu tun könnte wäre
eben diese transparenz nicht walten zu
lassen vielen dank herr merz der
dobrindt danke
alexander dobrindt und friedrich merz zu
dieser sitzungswoche aber auch zu den
schlagzeilen die es neben dieser
sitzungswoche gibt und da spielt
natürlich der krieg in der ukraine die
eine rolle und die andere frage die hier
immer mal wieder gestellt wird ist die
frage ob alles richtig war dass
christine lambrecht die
bundesverteidigungsministerium sich hat
begleiten lassen auf einer reise mit
einem bundeswehr hubschrauber
und ob das ganze rechtens gewesen ist
wir haben es man kann das so ein
bisschen deuten auch die reaktion jetzt
von friedrich merz und alexander
dobrindt die kritik ist doch
einigermassen verhalten und friedrich
merz hat auch noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass das durchaus wenn es
den richtlinien entspricht im grunde
nichts verwerfliches und schon gar nicht
was strafbares ist und ich glaube man
dass diese geschichte in 14 tagen dann
auch wieder aus den schlagzeilen
verschwunden sein wird sie merken es
möglicherweise im hintergrund vor mir
das bild ist nach wie vor etwas
ungewohnt nämlich es ist relativ viel
leben wieder auf der fraktionsebene im
reichstagsgebäude die abgeordneten tagen
wieder in ihren fraktions seelen und es
ist tatsächlich mehr bewegung ein
kleines bisschen mehr unruhe aber
insgesamt auch ein fröhliches hin und
her und das haben wir monatelang
tatsächlich doch einigermaßen und
gelegentlich auch schmerzlich vermisst
aber so langsam scheint auch auf dieser
seite auf dieser ebene in diesem fall
auf der fraktionsebene auch im deutschen
bundestag das leben wieder einigermaßen
sich zu normalisieren wir schauen auf
für die nächste fraktion in diesem
reigen an diesem dienstag und das ist
die vor einem bündnis 90 die grünen da
ist die stimmung allenthalben ähnlich
gut wie eben auch schon bei friedrich
merz das ja auch schon angedeutet hat
sie die grünen haben insbesondere in
schließlich deutschland ein sehr gutes
wahlergebnis erzielt und ihre beiden
minister oder zwei ihrer minister in
dieser bundesregierung machen durchweg
positive schlagzeilen und haben sich
auch in der beliebtheitsskala weit nach
oben gearbeitet
anita berber auch die außenministerin
beispielsweise die wir in den nächsten
minuten übrigens auch noch sehen werden
zu ihrer reise nach kiew ist als erstes
kabinettsmitglied in die ukraine gereist
wird also auch da eine ganze menge zu
erzählen haben von diesem besuch es gibt
erste bilder dass sie in einer kirche in
einem vorort von kiew kerzen angezündet
hat im gedenken an die opfer dieses
krieges und insbesondere der gräueltaten
der russischen armee in eben diesem ort
also insofern bei den grünen derzeit
gute laune gute stimmung aber sie
vergessen dabei natürlich nicht den
ernst der lage insbesondere in der
ukraine und deswegen hat auch katharina
dröge die co-fraktionsvorsitzende
mit diesem thema begonnen
wir haben mit sorge gestern auf die rede
von buddy putin zum neunten mal geschaut
und die schlechte nachricht die von
seiner rede ausgeht ist dass der
präsident mit dem weg von gewalt und
zerstörung und vernichtung den er eine
praline gerade geht weiter machen wird
er hat zwar nicht die befürchtete
generalmobilmachung verkündet aber ist
auf der anderen seite komplett in seinen
negativen geblieben es gibt kein
einziges zeichen dafür dass er von dem
bild der zerstörung den er jetzt geht
abkehrt
deswegen ist es richtig und wichtig dass
die eu gerade weiter verhandelt über
eine entschlossene antwort über ein
sechstes sanktionspaket dazu gehört aus
unserer sicht auch ein embargo auf öl
was jetzt schnell beschlossen werden
sollte und auf der anderen seite war es
sehr wichtig dass der bundeskanzler am 8
mai einen wichtigen und historischen tag
für deutschland dem tag der befreiung
von den nationalsozialisten eine rede an
die menschen in diesem land gehalten hat
um die politik der regierung in dieser
schwierigen zeit in einer zeit in der
der europäische frieden so sehr bedroht
ist und auch zerstört wird von vladimir
putin in der er diese politik erklärt im
deutschen bundestag stehen in den
nächsten zwei wochen dazu auch wichtige
entscheidungen an eine der wichtigsten
entscheidungen ist die über ein
sondervermögen zur stärkung der bündnis
und verteidigungsfähigkeit für uns grüne
ist sehr klar dass die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr in einem sehr schwierigen
zustand ist und deswegen mehr
investitionen auch in die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr
notwendig sind gerade in dieser zeit
verantwortung für den desolaten zustand
der bundeswehr ausrüstung trägt die
union sie hat 16 jahre lang die
verteidigungsminister in diesem land
gestellt und deswegen ist die union
jetzt auch in der verantwortung
gemeinsam mit uns eine lösung für dieses
ausrüstungs problem der bundeswehr zu
finden deswegen ist es positiv dass die
union sich auf gespräche zu einem
sondervermögen eingelassen hat wir
wünschen uns von friedrich merz dass er
diese gespräche ernsthaft führt dass er
hier keine spiele spielt dafür ist die
zeit zu ernst und ernsthaft bedeutet aus
unserer sicht dass sicherheit im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert auch
tatsächlich breit definiert wird es ist
absurd zu sagen dass eine stärkung der
sicherheit im 21 jahrhundert alleine
eine stärkung der bundeswehr ist und
beispielsweise themen wie die stärkung
von cyber sicherheit nicht mit in den
blick genommen werden darf und das
zweite ist gerade in einer zeit die so
ernsthaft ist wie diese sollten wir auch
die regeln der parlamentarischen
demokratie
waren und deswegen finde ich es eine
frage von ernsthaftigkeit das wenn man
sich mit einer fraktion am ende auf
einen kompromiss einigt dass dann auch
die gesamte fraktion in der lage ist
diesen kompromiss zustimmen zu dürfen
und dass nicht ein großteil der
abgeordneten von ihrem
fraktionsvorsitzenden gezwungen wird zu
hause zu bleiben wenn sie es eine sache
richtig findet gleichzeitig haben wir
heute morgen wieder die nachricht
bekommen diesmal vom expertenrat der
vereinten nationen dass die klimakrise
immer stärkerer geschwindigkeit ihre
fahrt aufnimmt und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir auch als deutsche
bundesregierung schnell und entschlossen
handeln
die bundesregierung und wir als ampel
fraktionen haben angekündigt dass wir
jetzt zum sommer ein klimaschutz
sofortprogramm beschließen werden dass
in allen sektoren unsere handlungsziele
beschreibt einer der sektoren die am
meisten noch liefern müssen ist der
verkehrssektor und hier ist es wichtig
dass jetzt auch verkehrsminister wissing
schnell ins handeln kommt schnell die im
koalitionsvertrag beschlossenen
maßnahmen umsetzt das heißt wissen muss
dafür sorgen dass es mehr geld für den
ausbau der schieneninfrastruktur gibt
deswegen muss dafür sorgen dass es mehr
geld für den ausbau des öpnv aus in den
kommunen gibt deswegen muss auch dafür
sorgen dass die bearbeitung des
bundesverkehrswegeplans so voran kommt
dass nicht weiterhin geld für unsinnige
straßenbauprojekte versenkt wird und
dass es zu einer stärkung des fuß- und
radverkehrs kommt ich bin froh dass der
verkehrsminister heute morgen und noch
einmal sehr klar deutlich gemacht hat
dass eine drastische ausweitung der
förderung für elektromobilität nicht zu
den maßnahmen gehört die für diese
bundesregierung in frage kommen ja so
viel von katharina dröge der
fraktionschefin der grünen so viel für
den moment aus dem deutschen bundestag
jetzt gehen wir zu ihrer parteifreundin
außenministerin annalena baerbock die
ist heute in kiew zu besuch heute morgen
war sie in butter zur stunde so hören
wir aus kiew wird sie die deutsche
botschaft dort wieder eröffnen und sie
hat sich ebenfalls heute schon getroffen
mit ihrem ukrainischen amtskollegen
cholera und hier ist die pressekonferenz
dazu
erst im februar war anna lena bereits
bei uns in kiel
danach und jetzt ist sie mal wieder da
wir haben mit aller länder gesprochen
und so fühl mich
ja und jetzt haben wir gründlich
gesprochen
und anna lena nach der
besuch in butter
hat noch schlimmere eindrücke gewonnen
und sie konnte sich
überzeugen es was die russische
aggression für ukraine bedeuten und ich
hoffe dass alle deutsche begreifen
können
also ganz einfache tatsache
die friedlichen ukraine
sterben jeden tag
der russischen beschüsse egal wo die
ukrainer sich befinden in der nähe der
front oder im
hinterland vor wenigen tagen auf wurde
immer
besser eine familie mit kleinkind
getötet
und
wir haben
gerade heute die schreckliche nachricht
bekommen im osten der ukraine
[Musik]
sind
44 leichen die an zivilisten geborgen
aus den trümmern in einer
ostukrainischen start
dieses haus wurde
noch vor gewissen zeit
zerstört worden immer zuge
des beschusses und was müssen wir uns
vorstellen wir befinden uns in unserem
haus und plötzlich müssen sie ja sterben
weil die russen
unser haus und unser land für sich in
anspruch nehmen
und
jeder von uns in der ukraine kann nicht
sicher sein ob man am morgen aufwachen
wird weil die russische rakete erreichen
uns im westen wie im osten des landes
an dieser stelle möchte ich
dir bundesrepublik
gedanken
stetige unterstützung bei der lösung von
ganz erreicht ihren aufgaben da die
politik da können wir sagen der erste
rakete am ersten kriegstag sie ein
wohnhaus im tier und getroffen hat hat
auch die deutsche politik bezüglich des
russisch-ukrainischen konflikt das
verändert und wie wir wissen der
bundeskanzler hat eine neue politik
angesagt und die
deutsche politiker mussten einsehen dass
die bisherige politik deutschlands gegen
uni war russland fehlerhaft war und
heute
entscheidet sind die zukunft der
europäischen entwicklung sie hier in der
ukraine
es kommt darauf an
putin wieder zum stehen gebracht wird
oder
wir dass putin doch gelingen die ukraine
für
vorposten die attacke auf europa
verwandeln
wir möchten kein europäisches land in
den krieg
wir brauchen keine ausländischen
soldaten hier in der ukraine
wir kämpfen selber und wir vergießen
unser eigenes brot im kampf
wir brauchen nur die stetige
unterstützung und in diesem sinne hoffen
wir darauf dass unsere freunde in europa
ihre unterstützung für uns fortsetzen
und ausbauen würden betrug das ist
heutzutage gibt es keine vorlage kein
geschichtsbuch
oder keine norm die besagt wie
waffenlieferungen an einen tempel des
land
einer kriegsbeteiligung
wir dieser narrativ verbreitet eben die
achim von youtube briten mit dem ziel
mehr menschen hier in der ukraine in
aller ruhe töten zu können
und ein groß angelegtes bouchard hier
einfluss
haben wir heute mit anna-lena
das thema
waffenlieferungen und europäische
integration sehr detailliert besprochen
wir beide sind durchaus interessiert an
der
schnellstmögliche umsetzung und
verabschiedung des sechster
aktionspakete die europäischen union
gegen über russland ist
und wir schätzen sie deutsche aktivität
und im rahmen der überwindung des
ungarischen embargo des
ungarischen vitus in bezug auf im lager
für
russische öllieferungen nach europa
es geht ja darum
dass
europa immer noch
die russische invasion in der ukraine
auch dem auf den unwillen finanzieren
gezwungen ist indem sie die russischen
energieträger lieferungen nach europa
bezahlen und ich hoffe dass früher oder
später die ukraine
gleichberechtigtes mitglied der grossen
europäischen
familie wird ich möchte noch einmal
betonen die ukrainische mitgliedschaft
ist
der beitrag zur stärkung der
europäischen union
sobald
das begreift
es werden keine spielchen oma
ukrainische
mitgliedschaft in der eu
gespielt
wird er seine anstrengungen unterlassen
die ukraine in der seiner einflusssphäre
zu behalten
die ukraine gehört
daheim
in europa und das lässt sich nur die
ein weiteres kandidat schafft für die
ukraine erreichen
meine kollegin anna lena aber heute
schockiert durch die verbrechen in
butter und wir haben dass die mal
gesprochen via russland zur
verantwortung gezogen werden könnte und
zum schluss
schwimmer zweiten weltkrieg hat der nasa
regime die bisherigen verbrechen
begangen
und sie deutschland musste nach dem
zweiten
weltkrieg den schmerzhaften prozess
durchgehen
all dies zu auf das
aufzuarbeiten
heutzutage haben wir mit dem ähnlichen
verbrecherischen regime zu tun und die
russen müssen auch durch buße
ihrer schuld an den militär verbrechen
in die ukraine zu tilgen
dass das was die tatsache dass die
bundesrepublik heutzutage
die souveränität und die integrität der
ukraine in schutz nimmt
das ist der große historische umbruch
und sie ich bin der der bundesregierung
dafür auf das dichte dankbar ja wir
haben noch einige strittige punkte
die einer diskussion bedürfen aber ich
bin überzeugt wir werden
akzeptable lösungen für jede frage
finden vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit schenken
tag sehr geehrte damen und herren sehr
geehrter kollege
lieber dimitrow ich bin heute wirklich
froh nicht nur als außenministerin
sondern als freundin hier in kiew zu
sein und vor allen dingen in einem
freien kiew zu sein
und um es ehrlich zu sagen in finsteren
tagen nach dem 24 februar hatte ich
zweifel ob ich diesen satz so bald sagen
würde ich habe es gehofft die es alle
gehofft haben aber wir waren auch ebenso
verzweifelt angesichts der brutalität
die wir im februar erfahren mussten wir
waren fassungslos angesichts dieser
hemmungslosen brutalität und der
entschlossenheit russlands nicht nur
diese stadt der freiheit sondern die
schiere existenz dieses ganzen landes zu
vernichten und der mut mit dem das
ukrainische volk in denen die ukraine
nun ukraine das verhindert haben ist
kaum zu beschreiben
und zugleich ist so wichtig was du
gerade unterstrichen hast dieser krieg
ist auch in dieser jetzt zum glück nach
wie vor freien stadt nicht vorbei es
kann an jedem ort dieses landes eben
eine rakete eingeschlagen
und zugleich bedeutet der heutige besuch
für mich für unser land für die gesamte
freie welt dass wir seit dem 24 februar
ohne zweifel unverrückbar an der seite
der ukraine und des freien kurs stehen
wir haben mehr als deutlich verstanden
dass wirtschaftliche abhängigkeiten
keine sicherheit bringen wenn dem
aggressor das wohl seiner bevölkerung
einfach egal ist deshalb reduzieren wir
mit aller konsequenz unserer
abhängigkeit von russischer energie auf
null und zwar für immer
wir werden die der geografie in europa
nicht verändern können aber wir machen
gemeinsam klar dass es nach dem 24
februar keine verständigung mit russland
kein millimeter zurück bei den
sanktionen über den kopf der ukraine
hinweg geben kann
das nie wieder nie wieder darf es in
europa passieren dass im angesicht eines
aggressors der keine regelt achtet nicht
nur der frieden sondern eben auch die
freiheit genommen wird und dieses nie
wieder bedeutet dass wir an der seite
der ukraine stehen dass es nie wieder
keine straflosigkeit für die von
russland begangenen kriegsverbrechen für
die verschleppung für die mörder und
vergewaltiger geben darf deswegen werden
wir die internationalen ermittlungen
allen voran die des internationalen
strafgerichtshof politisch finanziell
und mit deutschen personal unterstützen
und du hast es bereits angesprochen
ich war mit der generalstaatsanwältin
heute in butter und in ihr team
und es hat mir noch einmal auf
eindringliche art und weise deutlich
gemacht wie wichtig diese internationale
aber eben auch die nationale
strafverfolgung ist es ist das eine
furchtbare bilder von ermordeten
männern und frauen von ermordeten
kindern in deutschland in der zeitung zu
sehen aber etwas anderes
vor ort zu sein für diese menschen
beerdigt wurden endlich beerdigt wurden
nachdem sie tagelang auf der straße
gelegen haben und daher unterstützen wir
eben nicht nur die arbeit des
internationalen strafgerichtshofs
sondern ich habe heute auch noch mal mit
der generalstaatsanwältin besprochen wie
wir die internationale unterstützung
besser koordinieren können weil es geld
mittlerweile genug gibt aber wir gerade
bei der forensik auch von deutscher
seite stärker und weiter unterstützen
können wir werden zudem zwei
staatsanwältinnen für sexualverbrechen
zusätzlich ermöglichen die bei dieser so
wichtigen arbeit unterstützung leisten
können und zudem das hat mein besuch
heute und das gespräch mit der
generalstaatsanwältin auch noch einmal
deutlich gemacht geht es eben nicht nur
um die beweise vor ort aus butter und
ihr team sondern von den millionen von
menschen die geflohen sind die
schlimmsten verbrechen vor ihrer flucht
erleben mussten nicht nur die geliebte
menschen getötet worden sind sondern wie
sie selbst in diesem moment opfer von
gewalt opfer von kriegsverbrechen opfer
von vergewaltigung geworden sind und
auch deswegen werden wir verstärkt eben
die beweissicherung auch in deutschland
unterstützen bzw verstärken und diese
beweise entsprechen dann gemeinsam
nutzen
darüber hinaus
ist es wichtig dass menschen die alles
verloren haben und auch dass es in ihr
kini also deutlich geworden dass eine
komplette stadt zum glück die stadt
verlassen konnte zum allergrößten teil
diejenigen die nicht ermordet worden
sind dass sie die chance haben
zurückkommen zu können zum einen mit
blick auf wohnraum aber zum anderen auch
mit blick auf wiederaufbau und
entwicklung
und auch im bereich der e mini nun
werden wir gerne als bundesrepublik
deutschland in zukunft stärker
unterstützen weil es eben nicht nur um
die militärische entminung gibt wo wir
ja seit langer zeit auch an eurer seite
stehen sondern jetzt geht es vor allen
dingen darum auch die entminung in
städten in dörfern in kommunen verstärkt
und zwar gemeinsam voranzutreiben damit
menschen wieder zurückkehren können nie
wieder heißt aber vor allen dass wir die
angegriffenen dass wir die ukraine in
ihrem existenzkampf
nicht alleine lassen
waffenlieferungen
sind kein selbstzweck sondern
waffenlieferungen in diesem moment fuhr
ein brutaler angriffskrieg gegen euer
land nach wie vor geführt wird auch wenn
die region wo wir heute zum glück
friedlich sein können verteidigt werden
konnte waffenlieferungen bedeuten dass
es nicht noch mehr von diesem
furchtbaren kriegsverbrechen die ich
heute noch mal so sichtbar vor augen
geführt bekommen habe in eurem land vor
allen dingen im osten geben kann und
wird und ich sage das sehr deutlich weil
so ein besucher eine außenministerin ja
auch immer wichtig ist mit blick auf das
was man tut als bundesrepublik in einen
anderen land ich kann mich vergessen
dass diese waffenlieferungen auch dafür
da sind dass eben kriegsverbrechen nicht
an anderen orten stattfinden können du
hast die mutter angesprochen die ein
drei monate altes kind hatte
bevor eine rakete ja alles nahmen was
ihr größtes glück war und dieser fall
ist in dieser mappe verankert die ich
heute auch übergeben bekommen habe über
200 kinder die seit dem 24
februar mädchen aus ihrem leben gerissen
worden sind wenn man hier einmal
durchblättert nicht nur als
außenministerin sondern als vater oder
als mutter dann zerreißt es einem das
herz und genau das ist unsere
verantwortung und deswegen unterstützen
wir euer land verstärkt jetzt auch
militärisch das bedeutet dass wir
zusätzlich zu den lieferungen die wir
bereits getan haben in wenigen tagen mit
der ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten an
der hochmodernen panzerhaubitze 2000
beginnen die wir gemeinsam mit den
niederlanden liefern werden und wir
arbeiten mit deutschen unternehmen daran
dass die ukraine hochmoderne systeme
bekommen kann um ihre städte auch gegen
zukünftige angriffe zu schützen
wir werden die europäische freie
marine weiter unterstützen humanitär
finanziell wirtschaftlich
technologisch politisch und in
energiefragen und zwar nicht nur heute
sondern vor allen dingen auch morgen und
langfristig deshalb nehmen wir heute
auch die minimal präsenz unserer
deutschen botschaft hier in kiew wieder
auf
zunächst in einem eingeschränkten
betrieb
und ich bin sehr froh dass mich
botschafterinnen frau feldhusen heute
hier begleitet und in zukunft auch
wieder in einer freien stadt arbeiten
kann
lieber dimitrow dass wir heute hier
stehen zeigt welcher selbsttäuschung
putin aufgesessen ist er hat geglaubt
unsere europäischen werte freiheit und
menschlichkeit machen dekadent und
schwach die ukraine hat bewiesen in
wahrheit ist es umgekehrt euer
freiheitswille macht euch stark
und das wissen dass ihr um eure
menschlichkeit kämpft gegen einer mail
die nur zynismus und terror kennt
deshalb markiert euer kampf ein
wendepunkt im wettstreit zwischen
liberalen demokratien und autokratischen
regime viele auf der welt die freiheit
und menschenrechte für ein auslaufmodell
hielten werden aus eurem beispiel ihre
schlüsse ziehen
ihr allein zahlt dafür einen
unvorstellbaren
herzzerreißenden preis aber euer erfolg
ist auch der erfolg von millionen
menschen auf der welt die für freiheit
und frieden kämpfen und darauf weiter
hoffen und auch deswegen stehen wir in
diesem moment und zwar als überwiegender
teil der weltgemeinschaft gemeinsam
zusammen an der seite der ukraine und
auch deshalb ist für mich klar die
ukraine ein fester teil europas ich
wünschte mir dass wir auf euren
beitrittswunsch eine starke überzeugende
antwort finden auch wenn es auf dem weg
zur eu vollmitgliedschaft keine
abkürzung geben kann weil das nicht noch
einmal passieren kann sind falsche
versprechungen aber ich betone hier ganz
konkret
vollmitgliedschaft wir brauchen dafür
vor allen dingen in der europäischen
union eine reform eine weitere
vertiefung auch das ist die lehre aus
diesem brutalen angriffs krieg und
zugleich sage ich deutlich jetzt ist
nicht der moment für
paragrafen reiterei
sondern jetzt ist der moment klare
position zu beziehen in zeiten von krieg
und frieden und wenn wir über den
kandidatenstatus sprechen da bin ich
zuversichtlich dass die eu
kommissionspräsident in die euch ja dazu
eingeladen hat einen guten weg finden
wird dass es keine leeren versprechungen
sind dass wir den weg für die innere
vertiefung der europäischen union geben
können und damit auch deutlich machen
können die ukraine gehört zu der
europäischen union
ich bin überzeugt wenn dieser krieg
vorbei sein wird und dieser krieg wird
enden wie lange er noch dauert das
wissen wir leider nicht aber dann wird
die ukraine frei und selbstbestimmt sein
das ist unser aller ziel und an dieser
seite kämpfen wir gemeinsam mit euch
dann gewinnen und die erste frage durch
schwelle
ja matthias bühler deutsche welle eine
frage an herrn außenminister kleber sie
ärgern sich gelegentlich über
deutschland zum beispiel zuletzt
bei der beim verbot der flagge bei der
gedenkzeremonie am 8 was müsste denn aus
ihrer sicht passieren damit das
verhältnis wieder so wird wie vor diesem
und an die außenministerin frau baerbock
sie waren am 8 anfang februar waren sie
hier auf jeden fall und da haben sie
sich sehr deutlich gegen
waffenlieferungen noch ausgesprochen
bereuen sie dass inzwischen und ist es
vielleicht auch einer der gründe dass
dafür dass deutschland anderen ländern
den partnerländern ja immer ein bisschen
hinterher stolpert bei diesen in dieser
waffen frage
vor allem
ich werde auf niemandem in meinem leben
böse
das ist mein prinzip
was die episode an gilt diese ihr wert
haben da würde ich
das nicht verallgemeinern sind die
entscheidung über verbot der klinischen
symbolik ist nicht auf die nationale
ebene
getragen worden sondern vorn
kommunalen organen in berlin das war
natürlich ein fehler weil dadurch die
nationale symbolik eines opfers die
aggression und die symbolik des
aggressors tag erstellt worden waren
der grund ja man darf ja in solchen
fällen verbessern
verteidigen auch jetzt dieselben werte
die auch in berlin so hoch geschätzt und
verteidigt werden
und außerdem
alle sich
natürlich nicht alles verboten
herangehen wäre ein
fehler und wenn jemand in berlin meint
die ukrainische lage in berlin und die
russische flagge in berlin sind
gleichwertig da müssen wir das mal noch
mal darüber nachzudenken ob wir unsere
beziehungen richtige richtung laufen
blicke auf ihre frage ich war ja kurz
vor ausbruch dieses krieges auch hier
und habe im deutschen bundestag gesagt
wenn man seine bisherige politik ändern
da muss man das im vollen bewusstsein
tun und das haben wir getan mit dem 24
februar wir haben es in den wochen davor
nicht getan und wir standen hier ja auch
auf einer gemeinsamen pressekonferenz
weil wenn man diesen weg ändert dann
kann man nicht zwei tage danach sagen
'oh jetzt haben wir uns noch mal anders
überlegt und das war vor dem ausbruch
diesen brutalen angriffskrieg eine
abwägung weil deutschland in dem moment
zugleich eben mit frankreich
hauptverantwortlich dafür war das
minsker abkommen wieder zum laufen zu
bringen das war unsere zentrale
hauptaufgabe in diesem moment und ich
ganz persönlich habe immer wieder auch
abgewogen wenn wir einen anderen schritt
gehen kurz vor dem 24
februar würde das dann der auslöser sein
den der russische präsident als vorwand
nutzen würde zu sagen jetzt kann ich der
ukraine den krieg erklären weil diese
ganzen verhandlungen die deutschland ja
eigentlich mit unterstützen sollte die
waren offensichtlich nicht so gemeint in
dem moment am 24 februar wo der
russische präsident deutlich gemacht hat
dass er keineswegs vorhatte zu
verhandeln sondern uns ins gesicht
gelogen hat haben wir deswegen unseren
politischen kurs geändert indem wir
deutlich gemacht haben jetzt liefern wir
auch waffen an die ukraine weil die
chance der verhandlung mit diesem moment
zerbombt worden ist und zwar ganz allein
vom russischen präsidenten von wladimir
putin und auf den einen halbsatz möchte
ich aber sagen den sie angesprochen
haben in dem moment haben wir uns
entschieden zu handeln und deutschland
trägt dabei eine führende verantwortung
weil wir das größte industrieland in der
europäischen union sind das sehen wir
jetzt zum beispiel auch bei den
schritten mit blick auf ausstieg auf
fossile energien wir können das als
europäerinnen und europäer nur gemeinsam
tun deswegen ist mir wichtig dass wir
jeden schritt den wir öffentlich
verkünden auch vorher so durchdacht
haben wie wir ihn auf dauer durchhalten
können ich habe das bei den sanktionen
deutlich gemacht die sanktionen können
nicht zurückgenommen werden wenn wir
spüren das hat auch wirtschaftliche
auswirkungen in deutschland nein sondern
erst wenn die ukraine wieder frei ist
und selbst bestimmt sagt wir können
wieder in frieden leben und das gilt
eben auch für diese waffenlieferung und
wir wissen dass wir gerade mit blick auf
die europäischen armeen weil wir immer
in frieden weiter leben wollten nicht in
jedem bereich 100 prozent ausgestattet
sind wie wir das für unsere
wehrhaftigkeit in diesem moment brauchen
und deswegen haben wir ganz klare
prioritäten gesetzt wann wir was liefern
können damit es auch geliefert wird und
ich glaube nicht dass wir da
hinterherlaufen sondern wenn wir uns
anschauen was wir bereits geliefert
haben sind das 16 millionen schuss
munition tausende granaten und
sprengkörper tausende panzerfäuste
tausende flugabwehrwaffen ist inga und
strela aber eben auch militärische
geräte wie nachtsicht fernrohre
sanitätsmaterial und verpflegung und in
dem moment wo deutlich gemacht worden
ist wir brauchen mehr haben wir genau
geprüft was können wir im bereich
gepanzerter fahrzeuge tun haben aber
deutlich gemacht zb bei den g platz auch
wir können die gags liefern wir wollen
die g platz liefern aber wir haben
selber nicht die munition das gehört zur
ehrlichkeit dazu weil was hilft es bei
der verteidigung wenn ich etwas
verspreche und dann kann nur ein teil
geliefert werden deswegen versuchen wir
gerade alles bei den ländern die die
munition liefern können dass diese
munition jetzt für die gepard auch
geliefert werden kann und wie gesagt der
nächste schritt sind hoch moderne
panzerhaubitzen das bedeutet dass wir
diese vor allen dingen dafür nutzen
können zur drohnen abwehr und zum
bodenradar und ich bin nicht durch
zufall heute hier gemeinsam mit meinem
niederländischen außenminister kollegen
body health care sind gemeinsam mit dem
zug gekommen aber wir haben von den
gemeinsam in den letzten wochen daran
gearbeitet dass wir zwischen niederlande
und deutschland gemeinsam diese
panzerhaubitzen liefern können weil es
auch hier wieder so der fall ist ein
land kann ich alles alleine liefern weil
wir selber nicht genug haben aber
deutschland wird jetzt 7 zur verfügung
stellen und wir werden vor allen dingen
die ausbildung die dafür nötig ist jetzt
beginnen und vor allen dingen die
lieferung wird abgeschlossen sein bevor
die ausbildung dann auch an den start
gehen kann das heißt das dass beides
hand in hand geht wenn die haubitzen
kommen dann sind entsprechend die
soldatinnen und soldaten auch mit
ausgebildet
und mehr und mehr kohle peter interfax
ukraine
noch eine kurze frage von interfax
ukraine die frage an minister kollege
wann ist die verabschiedung des nächsten
die aktion ein paket zu erwarten und wie
wir wissen
die bundesrepublik lieferte
panzerhaubitzen wie und wie lange dauert
die ausbildung der afghanischen soldaten
dazu also momentan laufen innerhalb der
eu die
diskussionen darüber wie die
schwierigkeiten bei der verabschiedung
des sechsten sanktionen paket zu
überwinden ist ja das ist die innere
angelegenheit der eu und das ist die
aufgabe der mitgliedstaaten
dieses problem zu lösen
man muss schon
vorwegnehmen sagen die das scheitern mit
der verabschiedung des sechsten pakets
würde ein beleg für die unfähigkeit der
eu bedeuten
alles das niederlande und deutschland
gemeinsam die zwölf panzerhaubitzen die
man braucht damit das ganze auch
funktioniert liefern kann wir liefern
sieben davon und diese lieferung wird
abgeschlossen sein bevor die ausbildung
abgeschlossen ist das heißt wenn die
soldatinnen und soldaten dann kommen
können sie sie auch sofort nutzen
[Musik]
die pressekonferenz von außenministerin
annalena baerbock und ihrem
us-amtskollegen kollege aus kiew das war
zeitversetzt aus sicherheitsgründen die
pressekonferenz das war der erste besuch
eines
kabinettsmitglied mitgliedes der
regierung von olaf scholz in kiew sie
wissen ist hat er diese diplomatischen
verwerfungen gegeben zwischen berlin und
kiew und mit diesem besuch von frau bär
box sind diese ausgeräumt frau berbalk
hat mehrmals erneut und deutlich betont
dass deutschland an der seite der
ukraine steht und im hinblick auf die
konkreten waffenlieferungen die jetzt
anstehen da geht es ja um 12
panzerhaubitzen die von deutschland und
den niederlanden also insgesamt zwölf
die von deutschland und den niederlanden
geliefert werden geht es jetzt also
zügig an die ausbildung und dann können
diese haubitzen dann auch im kampf um
den don was eingesetzt werden als das
war sehr deutlich was annalena baerbock
gesagt hat allerdings sagte sie auch es
gebe was den möglichen beitritt zur
europäischen union der ukraine angeht
kein abgekürzten verfahren sie hoffe
allerdings darauf dass es keine
paragrafen reiterei geben wird da geben
würde dafür ist die situation die
historische situation rund um den krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine zu ernst es
ist tag 76 bereits des krieges russlands
gegen die ukraine an diesem dienstag
heute wahrscheinlich zur stunde wird die
botschaft in kiew wieder eröffnet und
das ist sicher ein wichtiges politisches
signal für die ukraine aber auch wohl
für deutschland also liebe zuschauer so
viel dazu im laufe des nachmittags oder
des frühen abends werden wir dann
weitere töne und bilder aus kiew
bekommen zum besuch von aussenministerin
werburg ich sage es nochmal aus
sicherheitsgründen kann das ganze nicht
live gesehen wie sie es gewohnt sind bei
uns sondern erst zeitversetzt am
nachmittag dann die eröffnung die
wiedereröffnung der botschaft und dann
frühen abend trifft sie noch den ost den
bürgermeister von kiew klitschko also
soviel dazu
für den moment jetzt schauen wir wieder
zurück in den deutschen bundestag wir
haben ja vor unsere übertragung von der
fraktionsebene mit erhard scherfer
fohlen unterbrochen er hat uns
geschildert was dort zu erwarten ist in
dieser woche und er hat wenn ich richtig
mit gerechnet habe fehlen noch zwei
fraktionen oder
haargenau hans während er genauso ist es
da sind vielsprechend vorhin wie von
zauberhand verschwunden aber wir haben
in der tat noch was nach zu tragen und
wenn man die geografie des plenarsaals
zugrunde legt dann findet uns noch
rechtsaußen und linksaußen und das
machen wir der größe nach in diesem fall
das heißt wir beginnen mit der afg
fraktion die afg als partei aber auch
als fraktion ja im moment in großer
unruhe es gibt unklarheiten was die
führung angeht und wie es im kurs weiter
gehen soll in den kommenden monaten und
möglicherweise jahren es gab eine
wahlniederlage am vergangenen sonntag in
schleswig-holstein da ist die hälfte zum
ersten mal aus einem parlament wieder
rausgeflogen das ist man gar nicht
gewohnt gewesen in den vergangenen
jahren seit gründung der fdp so alt ist
sie ja noch gar nicht aber jetzt rumort
es hinter den kulissen wie gesagt nicht
nur in der partei auch in der fraktion
und eines der gründe für die einer der
gründe für dieses rumoren ist die
haltung gegenüber russland es gibt ja
eine ganz besondere beziehung einiger
mitglieder und abgeordneter zu russland
viele sind immer mal wieder dagewesen
haben auch die nähe zum kreml gesucht es
gibt abgeordnete die ganz offensiv
russische propaganda weiterverbreiten es
gibt aber auch eine ganze anzahl von
abgeordneten in der raf die die eine
andere vorstellung davon haben wie mit
russland umzugehen ist da ist dann aber
gleichzeitig auch schon wieder die davon
die rede dass es rede verbote gegeben
habe innerhalb der fraktion von denen
die den kurs putins kritisieren also
einiges in unruhe und den beiden kräften
an der spitze der fdp-bundestagsfraktion
gelingt es offenbar nicht ruhe in diese
diskussion reinzubringen und im
gegenteil es wird ihnen vorgehalten dass
sie nicht führen können oder nicht
führen wollen nichtsdestotrotz gehört zu
unserem gesamtüberblick auch die sich
der beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden der fdp
fraktion tino copala und alois seidl
ja herzlich willkommen hier zu unserem
pressegespräch
jeden dienstag vor der fraktionssitzung
wie sie wissen treibt uns die sorge in
der ukraine um
wir
haben sorge dass der konflikt das der
krieg immer weiter eskaliert
das leider nichts in die richtung getan
wird um friedensgespräche zu fördern
sondern das immer weiter an der
eskalationsspirale gedreht wird
warum wir uns eben auch wünschen frau
berbalk die grüne außenministerin
besucht die ukraine und es wäre
wünschenswert wenn sie auch moskau und
russland versuchen würde um den
gesprächskanal auch zu russland offen zu
halten denn davon würde ganz europa
profitieren wenn wir endlich in
friedensgespräche eintreten würden und
nicht die eskalationsspirale weiter
drehen durch überstürzte
waffenlieferungen panzerhaubitze
raketen und was weiß ich was sonst noch
etwas was deutschland und auch europa
zur indirekten kriegspartei macht und da
stoßen wir auch direkt an den kern des
problems was aus unserer sicht auf dem
diplomatischen parkett völlig übersehen
wird und zwar mit leben haben wir sie
eigentlich zu tun wir haben es mit einer
atommacht zu tun
die ein nachbarland
völkerrechtswidrig angegriffen hat die
ukraine hat jedes recht sich zu
verteidigen aber das heißt noch lange
nicht dass sich europa und deutschland
in das kriegsgeschehen hineinziehen
lässt durch waffenlieferung völlig
einseitig mit einer kriegsrhetorik die
die eskalationsspirale immer weiter
dreht und auch wladimir putin einen
gesichtswahrenden weg zurück an den
verhandlungstisch mehr und mehr verbaut
und dementsprechend appellieren wir an
die verhandler europas und auch unsere
bundesregierung alles tun um
friedensgespräche mit beiden parteien
einzutreten um möglichst schnell diesen
kriegerischen akt diesen kriegerischen
konflikt zu beenden
ja ich möchte vielleicht auf die
wirtschaftlichen folgen wir
hauptsächlich unsere bürger unsere
bürger in deutschland betreffen eingehen
hier geht es um das thema des ölembargos
was er aktuell in der eu diskutiert wird
ungarn möchte ja auf das geplante eu
embargo gegen russisches auf die
russischen importe mit einem veto
reagieren der bayerische
ministerpräsident handelt damit im
interesse und zum wohle seines volkes
und genau das würden wir uns von der
bundesregierung ebenso wünschen dass die
deutschen interessen hier berücksichtigt
werden und das auf dieses öl embargo
verzichtet wird ein embargo auf den
import von russischem erdöl hätte auch
und gerade für deutschland eben diese
enormen wirtschaftlichen schäden zur
folge für mehr region gerade im osten
deutschlands wäre es eine struktur und
auch eine sozialpolitische katastrophe
wenn sich dieses embargo durchsetzen
würde durch einen erzwungenen
betriebsstopp der pck raffinerie im
ostbrandenburgischen schwert während
mehrere tausend arbeitsplätze akut in
gefahr und die treibstoffversorgung in
den östlichen bundesländern wäre auch
nicht weiter mehr sichergestellt
aufweisen auch alle und mehrere ihk ist
mittlerweile in mehrere
wirtschaftsverbände was das für
wirtschaftliche folgen für die region
aber auch für die arbeitsplätze in
deutschland hätte auch der
chemiestandort leuna in sachsen anhalt
wäre von einem öl embargo unmittelbar
bedroht wir reden hier von über 100
unternehmen von mehr als 12.000
arbeitsplätzen direkt betroffen werden
die negativen effekte die sich daraus
für die ohnehin strukturschwachen
regionen in ganz deutschland
zwangsläufig ergeben sind dabei noch
nicht einmal mit berücksichtigt
sanktionen und das ist das was wir von
anfang an vertreten haben als afd
fraktionen aber auch als afd partei die
immer auch nicht zum wohle deutschlands
ausgerichtet sind die deutschland und
europa mehr schaden als russland sind in
jeder hinsicht unsinnig und daher auch
abzulehnen und da muss man wirklich die
frage sagen auch sie stellen warum
lassen wir die bürger nicht selbst
darüber entscheiden was gut für
deutschland ist und was nicht denn hier
acht wirklich auch die wahrnehmung
zwischen politik und den bürgern die das
ja schlussendlich auch bezahlen müssen
äußerungen wie die von
wirtschaftsminister habe wonach
deutschland vermeintlich eine
bringschuld gegenüber der ukraine haben
in bern wirklich hier auch jeder
grundlage und sind politisch mehr als
fragwürdig die deutsche bundesregierung
hat zuallererst die interessen der
deutschen bürger des volkes hierzu waren
und darin besteht auch die ihre erste
verantwortung sie darf daher derartige
eu vorhaben nicht unterstützen und
sollte hier dem beispiel ungarns von
vielen kino copala und alice weide mit
ihren statements in dieser sitzungswoche
des deutschen bundestages und natürlich
spielte auch da der krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine eine große rolle aber
aus einer etwas anderen perspektive als
wir das bei den anderen
fraktionsvorsitzenden gehört haben wir
kommen zu einer anderen partei die im
moment irgendwie in schwerem wasser
unterwegs ist nämlich zur linken es hat
schwere wahl debakel gegeben im saarland
das hat einen weiteren nicht einzug in
den landtag von kiel gegeben und auch
für nordrhein-westfalen am kommenden
sonntag sieht es nicht gut aus für die
linke dazu kommt eine zurückgetretene
parteivorsitzende und auch interne
diskussionen auch gerade was die
russlandpolitik angeht da ist man sich
keinesfalls einig da gibt es auch sehr
abweichende positionen bei den linken
nichtsdestotrotz hat amira mohammed ali
die vorsitzende der linksfraktion sich
auch genau zu diesem thema geäußert hier
heute mittag
zum ersten thema waffenlieferungen hier
spitzt sich die debatte ja weiter zu die
bundesregierung
will weiter waffen liefern und schwere
waffen auch liefern
ich möchte daran erinnern dass es
eigentlich einmal eine richtlinie gab
die bundesregierung die
vorgängerregierung sich selber gegeben
hatten nach den waffenlieferungen kriegs
und krisengebiete nicht stattfinden
diese regelung hat auch gründe gehabt
nämlich weil man durch solche
waffenlieferungen auch konflikte weiter
eskaliert es ist ein unserer ansicht
nach ein großer fehler dass diese
schweren waffenlieferungen jetzt
stattfindenden stattfinden sollen weil
sie die gefahr erhöhen dass der konflikt
sich weiter oder krieg sich weiter
ausweiten dass deutschland als
kriegspartei wahrgenommen wird und
entsprechend mit entsprechenden folgen
einer ausweitung dieses schrecklichen
krieges in der ukraine muss allerdings
unbedingt verhindert werden er muss den
krieg beenden so schnell es geht wir
sind der auffassung dass ein kriegsende
nicht mit waffengewalt erreicht werden
kann sondern dass das auf diplomatischen
wege nur erfolgen kann und ja ich weiß
das ist auch richtig wenn man das sagt
das war dem posieren im moment nicht
verhandlungsbereit erscheint dass es
völlig inakzeptabel aber umso mehr muss
die bundesregierung jetzt darauf drängen
dass entsprechende verhandlungen geführt
werden und entsprechend auch ich sag mal
diplomatisch alles tun um einen
waffenstillstand und ein ende dieses
krieges herbeizuführen
die gefahr durch die schweren
waffenlieferungen und eben auch durch
die ausbildung der soldatinnen und
soldaten der ukraine durch deutschland
besteht darin dass eben dadurch eine
eine teilnahme deutschlands an diesem
krieg ist es so gelesen werden kann es
gibt inzwischen einen einen bericht ein
gutachten des wissenschaftlichen
dienstes des bundestages wonach
deutschland dann zur kriegspartei werden
kann wenn sie ebenso klar wenn wir eben
ukrainische soldaten ausbilden es gibt
ja auch andere meinungen dazu aber es
ist zumindest die gefahr da wieder
besteht olaf scholz hatte bis vor kurzem
noch gesagt dass er um jeden preis
vermeiden will dass deutschland
kriegspartei wird danach sieht es im
moment nicht mehr aus und das ist
hochgefährlich ich möchte daran erinnern
russland ist eine atommacht das heißt
die situation ist brandgefährlich und es
müssen wege der deeskalation gegangen
und gefunden werden die
waffenlieferungen die ausbildung
afghanischer soldaten durch deutschland
sind da der falsche weg und das führt er
zur weiterer aggression oder eskalation
so ist es richtig
dann möchte ich etwas daten zum thema eu
ölembargo gegen russland nach
derzeitigem stand gibt es noch bedenken
von tschechien der slowakei und ungarn
gegen dieses embargo ungarn hat auch
angekündigt oder dass sie gegebenenfalls
auf eu-ebene veto dagegen einlegen
werden
die bundesregierung muss hier wirklich
ganz genau ab wegen welche auswirkungen
dieses öl embargo auf die versorgung der
menschen in deutschland auf die deutsche
wirtschaft hat und auf das was sie auf
der anderen seite inwiefern ein solches
öl embargo einen einfluss hat auf den
schrecklichen angriffskrieg wladimir
putins in der ukraine
bei zweiterem ist ein meiner ansicht
nach immer noch ein großes fragezeichen
ob ein öl-embargo überhaupt auswirkungen
auf den krieg hätte das heißt ob es dazu
führen würde dass der krieg schneller
beendet würde und auf der anderen seite
drohen für die menschen in deutschland
und eben auch für die wirtschaft in
deutschland ganz enorme risiken wir
wissen dass in ostdeutschland dass
ostdeutschland fast zu 100 prozent auf
die russischen gaslieferungen angewiesen
ist das heißt ein entsprechendes embargo
würde dazu führen dass die versorgung
und aus deutschland massiv gefährdet ist
und dass da eben auch wirtschaftszweige
zusammenbrechen und ich will da nur ein
beispiel sagen es ist
es gibt firmen die ausschließlich
russisches gas verarbeiten können
raffinerien die ausschließlich
russisches gas verarbeiten können und
deswegen ist es kann man da auch nicht
einfach umstellen und plötzlich von
anderen in anderen ländern gas beziehen
insofern wäre das ein enormes risiko für
ostdeutschland aber auch insgesamt für
die wirtschaft in deutschland und wir
sind der meinung dass dieser weg nicht
beschritten werden sollte denn die
folgen dafür können wirklich davon
können wirklich verheerend sein
amira mohammed ali vorsitzende der
linksfraktion mit ihrem blick auf
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und ein
mögliches öl-embargo gegenüber russland
das gab übrigens im anschluss an dieses
statement noch eine weitere
pressekonferenz und zwar unter anderem
von gregor gysi aber auch von gerhard
trabert dem sozialmediziner die beiden
sind mit einer kleinen delegation in der
ukraine unterwegs gewesen haben
krankenhäuser besucht und
hilfsorganisationen getroffen
spendengelder übergeben ausschnitte aus
dieser pressekonferenz gibt es dann bei
uns in der sendung der tag gegen 23 uhr
wir schauen noch mal ganz kurz auf die
sitzungswoche beispielsweise auf morgen
13 uhr befragung der bundesregierung da
wird der bundesjustizminister rede und
antwort stehen nämlich marco buschmann
gegenüber den abgeordneten und um 15 uhr
und fünf minuten gibt es eine aktuelle
stunde auf antrag der unionsfraktionen
es geht um das thema hunger vermeiden
mehr lebensmittel produzieren statt
ackerflächen stilllegen das wird
sicherlich eine muntere debatte geben
denn in der ampel koalition gibt es
durchaus andere vorstellungen was
flächenstilllegungen angeht und am
donnerstag um 9 diesen punkt will ich
gerade noch erwähnen drei gesetzentwürfe
der bundesregierung zur energiewende die
die energiewende beschleunigen sollen im
land aber auch das
steuerentlastungsgesetz spielt eine
große rolle im laufe des tages und
überdies die bafög-reform so viel an
diesem dienstag aus dem deutschen
bundestag von der fraktionsebene im
reichstagsgebäude wie gesagt morgen um
13 uhr sind wir wieder da und donnerstag
und freitag natürlich auch wie gewohnt
das war's an dieser stelle und ich gebe
entspannt und elegant zurück zu hans
werner fittkau dafür nach erhard
scherfer das war teil zwei an schärfe
und die fraktionsebene ich sage danke
dafür nach berlin liebe zuschauer
willkommen auf die politische stimmung
im lande die stimmung ist nach wie vor
auf geheiß corona querdenker und jetzt
auch der